[Music]
what are you doing
uh they were just asking about the
family who's about to tell us about her
super awesome guests oh mirabelle didn't
get one
you didn't get a gift
um
delivery
i gave you the special since you're the
only madrigal kid with no gift i call it
the nut special special since uh you
have no gift
thanks
oh and antonio good luck last gift
ceremony was a bummer last one being
yours that did not work
if i was you i'll be really sad
well my little friend i am not because
the truth is gift or no gift i am just
as special as the rest of my family
all right guys where do i drop the wagon
maybe your gift is being in denial
many years ago
this scandal blessed our family with a
miracle
our house our casita
[Music]
in time every member of our family
cecilia
was
[Music]
the donkeys got out again
or effortlessly perfect like senorita
perfect isabella
but my mom
why am i the only one that didn't get a
gift you're just as special as anyone
else in this family
you just healed my hand with an adepa
arepa
what's going on
the magic is in danger we gotta get out
of here we must protect our home we must
protect our family
this is my chance i will save the magic
wait
how do i save the magic
[Music]
the rats told me everything don't eat
those
even in our darkest moments
there's light
where you least expect it
[Music]
a lot of stairs
but at least i'll have a friend nope he
flew away immediately quitter
[Music]
foreign